in rural cavity Georgia's most
successful banker celebrates the opening
of a new hotel
it's a side venture politics is now
maluca hazards main business this summer
hazards
launched his political party nello on
the Black Sea at the sight of his
ambitious two and a half billion dollar
deep-sea port but the port's future is
in question Georgia's government has
delayed its support and hazard Z and the
business partner are fighting a separate
fraud investigation accused of
laundering nearly 17 million dollars
through their bank TBC Hazzard adds a
has entered politics to fight back
courting voters and challenging the
government on primetime TV and in life
there is a certain line which you don't
want to cross should you made a deal
with them or change not only for you but
change country's future so and that's
why I just decide to leave business the
government party since hundreds a has to
answer for the missing millions and you
are just creating lounging the political
party you have to say something or at
least hate about what happens dream to
make a success of this country the way
he made a success of his business empire
but is he just another Aligarh making
his move a case of history repeating
[Music]
billionaire Bidzina Ivanishvili entered
politics promising to rescue Georgia
from poverty and a power-hungry elite
the one landslide elections in 2012
hazards a dislikes the comparison it's
not about myself it's about those people
who are joining lay low the young people
they are easy to spot encourages
frequent anti-government demonstrations
and it just about the idea and idea it's
Georgia and I think we we have a big
chance to change this country to make it
very successful he may be a banker who
knows how to build a business it's not
clear yet how many Georgians will sing
to his tune in for a steelworker
Jazeera